how's it going everybody got some news
for the arrowverse today
each year the arrowverse does a
crossover and last year's crossover
featured a ton of heroes from arrow the
flash Supergirl
legends of tomorrow as well as many
other heroes but of course this year
everybody is looking forward to the
Dubuque Ruby Rose as Batwoman just a
reminder my giveaway continues if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray or ant-man and the wasp some
special edition posters and some special
memorabilia all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
Stephen Amell said that we should stay
tuned today and expect some big reveal
regarding Batwoman
however this photo was actually leaked
before they did their reveal many
Twitter accounts that I've been posting
this photo have been suspended so we
know that this is real and as you can
see here Ruby Rose as Batwoman looks
amazing and the costume looks amazing as
well not only does it look amazing but
it's also extremely comic-book accurate
everything from the red hair the red
lipstick the pale skin the red Batwoman
logo on her chest the red utility belt
they did go a little light with the red
on the underside of her cape however I
still think it looks very good I think
fans were looking forward to seeing how
Ruby Rose would look as Batwoman for
some time now and I don't think any of
them are going to be disappointed we're
still expecting some sort of reveal from
Stephen Amell today so perhaps we'll get
an even better look later on
DC's annual air overs crossover the last
three days and it starts on December 9th
let me know what you all think of this
first look at Ruby Rose as Batwoman
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything related to
Batwoman thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]